[Musica]
sono carico sono carico per un motivo e
questo no aspetta che questo io ho degli
amici fantastici
grazie raga allora ho ricevuto un dono
da step 23 17 poi devi spiegare il
perché del numero perché non è meglio
quanto ha spiegato voglio sapeva bene
così apri wannsee trash è ricordata mi
piaceva un sacco staskin io quando dico
i nemici mi piace quella skilo romena
prendono perché sono amici fantastici
va bè ragazzi benvenuti a questo slide
park o come si chiama è tutto buio
sbaglio è tutto buio meno male che nella
copertina si voterà no ma capendo anno
ma scusa l'arrivo questa qua e la
partenza
credo che questo tipo della
presentazione creerà presentazi la intro
perché tutto tremendamente buio ok
questo il 12 non i due come prossimo
aspetta chi se ne frega andiamo avanti
perché la matematica è un'opinione in
questo gioco certa morbido la classe già
morto ah ecco
vamonos e riproviamo non l'avevo visto
assolutamente non si fa scoraggiare a te
mio dio
uno è un casino questa notte come
bisogna schivare i gommoni perché arrivi
si rallenta e credo di sì ci provo
ritorna a ramadi riprova che ho capito
deve schivare il sito no ma orribile
raga ce l'ha fatta
trovata solo perché io ce l'ho fatta ha
detto effetto
adesso il marito stefano è finito
abbiamo un problema troppo dimmi dimmi
cos'è
ecco 9 nov abera che mi aspettano non è
possibile ma come non c'è un check poi
abbiamo presentazione non è una forma fa
normale fuggono devi correre all'inizio
quella la tattica
ok ok poi devi fare cose che non ho
capito ce l'ho fatta come amici ce l'ha
fatta
no no no me come nova per haga sto
malissimo ho fatto non so descritto
dovete vedere il pezzo del video e dove
bisogna andare è non lo so perché aiuta
devi cadere sotto mentre sotto perfetto
ce l'ho fatta c'è poi a livello 13
questo spunta jason sicuro vado prima
chi va tu prima le signore oggi mi
sembri contento sono contento di morire
ecco visto poi io non vorrei dire una
una blasfemia ma in realtà quando si
utilizzi il joystick queste cose con un
tweet che vigliacco ok capirà questo
joystick ho fatto subito la prima parte
ragazzi minimi questo
mamma mia che difficile lo fa prima si è
fatto così fatta no ero arrivato perché
quando provi a fare dei partiti ci di un
certo tipo tivoli slide con joystick
vescovi facile lo so è un rosa è più
reattivo mio dio ce lo da jesi
voglio sempre all'ultimo allora fate in
su penso che pare che voleva rete
superficie fatta ce l'hai
mio dio mia mamma mi avevo soprattutto
un pochettino però è andata bene va bene
next vabbè cos'è sta roba riguardo step
abbiamo sei partite gli avengers
bravissimo non ha idea di quanto ti
spingerà dalla parte opposta e preparati
ma aspetta ma se si porta dove sono
morto perché non aveva preso il ghiaccio
le scocche i gay
mamma mia mio dio mio dio è vabbè ma
abbiamo un problema davvero mamma mia
ragazzi che sta veramente difficile le
scale ma proprio lui tu corni miley
shifty lino perché tutta la corsa
automatica esatto sto costruendo per
sbaglio maledizione io non sono mai
riusciti a fare il cambio ne devi andare
completamente a destra completamente ha
così esatto
adesso no no no no è devi fare qualche
quali devi stare attento perché ti frega
se faceva trazione l'ultimo salto ce
l'ho fatta mamma mia madre più lui
allora qua vedo della magia sembrava
questa magica quella io d'arredo che sia
uno slide tutto nella foresta dove con
grill e non vediamo lente di quello che
sta succedendo perfetto sto facendo cosa
stai girando
sì perché non sembra impossibile però ho
sbattuto contro un tronco e sono morto
gigi vuole cara sinistra erano questo
può essere ma da sinistra va ipad
sinistra proprio non mi viene scomoda
andare a sinistra e patristica magari a
quello che mi vuole l'ho fatto non è
vero
no ma l'inizio non devi andare a destra
o arrivato al tronco vai ancora destra
ti butti su ad essa come se non ci fosse
un tomorrow land bravo al i e ii li hai
capito
ok impara capito troppo andati è
difficilissimo poi è bello che ha messo
troppo lo comunque dunque tifernina
ok è una c doors mascherata praticamente
a destra no o la corri bile la roccia li
orribile throw duro forse puoi andare
anche a sinistra del tronco sai dove non
c'è nessuna roccia bici sì perché ho
provato a vedere adesso e sembra che tu
vada nel fango però in realtà nel fango
non è che ti uccide quindi ok sinistra
speck e provo ok se sto scherzando il
fango ti ammazza era completamente
sbagliata la miglioramento
ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta aiuto è
tutto buio tranquillo
oh mio dio a livello 16 ce l'ho fatta e
stata un anziano siamo divisi quasi a
divisi abbiamo due versioni diverse di
questo livello ha fatto e come possibile
ma siccome abbiamo accorsi e diverse è
quindi sarà un po diverso l'inizio e poi
si unisce esatto
ok eccolo eccolo buy
ecco può ci sono allora ci sono solo
fortissimo nell'andare avanti fermati
qui c'è una trappola
ok questa sono in grado di attivarla
anche bisogna vederla ho imparato a
farlo quella dove è un po peggio slide
di il problema è che quegli scalini sono
pagati e io in 20 minuti nell'altro del
modo di farli funzionare
qua sotto di noi c'è una trappola non
pro vasto portare avanti stimo e se
muoio io prevedo nozze ho provato era un
casino dobbiamo per forza a scivolare io
con quegli scalini rimango bloccato dai
ragazzi finiamo al 16 perché è pagato
purtroppo è pagato ma è in realtà
avevano torto anche il modo di
sbagliarlo ma è difficile lo stesso però
oggi va bene così sponda evitare di
stare 8 ore ma registra la stessa mappa
se volete continuo iscrivetevi
quindi ragazzi spero che si sia piaciuto
ringrazio come al solito stef.ar per la
loro partecipazione anche se fare l'ho
visto al primo livello e basta però sono
a14 adesso ho fatto dei progressi
chissenefrega ragazzi siete iscritti ai
canali state fair che trovate come
sempre schizzare e noi come sempre ad un
prossimo video bari
[Musica]